we have a real and true national
security red alert here to discuss
and it comes down to fundamentally
uh pushing through the last
possible stand of uh
keeping something sacred in the sense of
keeping it outside of the reach of
political
machinations or machinations as some
like to say
which is that donald trump's
intelligence officials
are no longer going to be briefing
democrats
with a question mark as to whether they
will be briefing joe
biden as the nominee of the democratic
party
for president and uh house member
adam schiff has sounded the alarm on
this over the weekend he said that
his committee may end up having to
subpoena intelligence officials because
john ratcliffe who's the director of
national intelligence announced
that regular election security briefings
were going to be scaled back ahead of
the general election instead of actually
briefing
members of the democratic party they are
going to give them some written
documents which of course provides no
opportunity to ask questions now this
is not only obviously political
but it is also obviously related to
upcoming election interference that the
trump administration itself
doesn't have an interest in stopping why
because on balance it's expected to be
beneficial to him so here is donald
trump being asked about this
recently he says the reason is leaks
leaks leaks adam schiff and whoever they
would brief
would just leak the information take a
look whether it was shifty shift
or somebody else they leak the
information before it gets in
and what's even worse they leaked the
wrong information
and he got tired of it so he wants to do
it in a different form
because you have leakers on the
committee obviously uh leakers that are
doing bad things
probably not even legal to leak but
we'll look into that separately
but they were leaking the information as
brought in how you don't have that in
texas
ken you wouldn't allow that in texas i
guarantee ken will not be allowing the
leakers to be doing that so
we were uh he wanted to make sure that
it doesn't leak yeah please mr president
so this is a lie that this is just not
true
the real reason why the trump
administration
has directed the intelligence community
to stop
briefing democrats as reported by
politico
is that classified security briefings
were given to members of congress and in
those briefings
william evening who's the direction
director of the national
counterintelligence and security center
said russia is trying to help
trump win russia is trying to denigrate
joe biden in order to help donald trump
win
win so what does the trump
administration do they say
stop telling democrats that that's
what's going on
um you might remember and this is why
this is so important i mean the
we don't have to theorize about the
implications of this
think back to 2016. when barack obama
was president
and donald trump was the challenger the
republican nominee
barack obama's intelligence officials as
is tradition as should be the case
briefed barack obama and donald trump
about
russia's interests in helping donald
trump to win
about the steele dossier and the
information contained
within it and if you think back to that
and you uh uh consider
the importance of these briefings you
then
very quickly realize the only real
reason that donald trump would have
to say stop briefing democrats is he
doesn't want them to
know what is in those security briefings
because it is not particularly good for
donald trump for that information to be
known and
what we know what william evanina was
saying
has been reported otherwise which is
yeah russia prefers
donald trump period now many will write
to me and say but david
china prefers biden and iran prefers
biden
okay yeah we i've told you that we've
discussed that uh
that that i'm not denying that
and there are geopolitical reasons for
all of the preferences that other
countries have but donald trump is
specifically trying to prevent
one perspective from getting out there
and that is that once again russia has
an interest in helping donald trump win
so
these people need to be held accountable
uh step one for accountability is
november third
that's the most pressing one it's
september now we are two months uh we we
are just weeks
essentially from this election votes are
going to start being cast in some places
i think it's within 10 days some states
will start early voting so step one for
holding accountable
is removing donald trump then we are
going to have to see
where the chips fall and who was
involved in wrongdoing and while there
is
i believe no real possibility that
donald trump
is charged with anything once he's no
longer president i know that there's
people dreaming of trump in handcuffs
that's not what the u.s
does to former presidents it's not my
opinion
it's just the reality that doesn't mean
that there aren't
other people could it be don jr could it
be jared kushner could it be people
whose names maybe we don't know
who should and could be held accountable
and we're going to have
to see they're not even trying to hide
it there's foreign meddling again
and trump's interference is in getting
in the way of people learning
about what russia is doing consider that
and by the way just look back at the
last four years
of getting in the way of any serious
attempt to actually
stop foreign meddling why would he try
to stop it it's useful
to him i want to take a second to tell
you about one of our sponsors
susman and han sussman and han has
everything you need
when it comes to face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off sussman and han is the company that
i personally have been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor
i have tried tons of different masks
this year
and i still have not found a mask that's
more comfortable or easier to breathe in
than the washable cotton masks that they
sell it's made of a silky lightweight
cotton that feels great on your skin
it has convenient adjustable straps it
features a disposable five layer
particle filter made of activated carbon
they also have disposable cloth masks
which are really comfortable as well as
other gear
like face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love sussman and han
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions they're
a great company
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is underneath this video
and you can save
20 percent off of everything in their
store when you use the coupon code david